nîmes à jean castex a reçu une première
dose d'astrazeneca face aux caméras mais
cela n'a pas suffi beaucoup de français
restent réticents à ce vaccin
dimanche dernier à la sortie de ce
centre parisien réservé aux personnels
prioritaires de plus de 55 ans les
volontaires étaient bien peu nombreux on
ne pose pas de problème je vienne été
informé par le médecin du centre sur les
risques infime de thrombose et l'acsi
nation astrazeneca mais bon j'ai préféré
me faire vacciner
d'ores et déjà et donc n'avait pas le
choix du médecin je l'accepté sans
problème il y a plus de deux genres pour
vous accueillir que deux patients c'est
à dire qu'il ya très peu du monde
je suis même étonnée qu'on ait aussi peu
à nice un centre qui devaient rester
ouverts tout le week-end à fermer faute
de candidats dès samedi midi
lui aussi ne proposait que l'astra
zeneca nous avons eu seulement 58
personnes qui se sont présentés le matin
pour quatre mille doses de vaccins
disponibles
la suspension pour quelques jours du
vaccin en france au mois de mars est
encore dans les mémoires
la faute à quelques rares cas de
thrombose chez certaines personnes
plutôt jeunes dans les jours suivant la
vaccination depuis sa nouvelle
autorisation mi mars le gouvernement a
décidé de réserver l'astra zeneca ou
plus de 55 ans à ce jour l'agencé
nationale de sécurité du médicament ne
dénombre que huit décès pour 2 millions
700 mille doses d'astrazeneca injecté en
france ce jeudi
olivier ferrand dans sa conférence de
presse hebdomadaire dédiée au virus a
voulu consacrer sa première réponse à la
défiance subie par le vaccin
astrazeneca c'est un vaccin à l'action
on ne peut plus classique en matière de
vaccination en cours depuis des
décennies dans plein de maladies comme
d'autres vaccins comme la plupart des
vaccins qui comme beaucoup de
médicaments d'ailleurs il peut donner ce
qu'on appelle des effets indésirables
passagers sans gravité dans deux traits
harkat il peut provoquer des thromboses
c'est à dire la formation de petit
caillou qui peuvent aller bouchée des
haines qui peuvent déboucher la
circulation veineuse et provoquer pour
le coup des effets indésirables plus
graves mais ils sont très rares face à
la circonspection des français le
gouvernement envisage un grand plan de
communication des personnalités du monde
de la culture seraient sollicités selon
le canard enchaîné le premier ministre
aimerait même que la chanteuse sheila se
fassent vacciner devant les caméras quoi
qu'il en soit aucun vaccin ne sera perdu
la france prévoit de faire don de sang
windows d'astrazeneca à des pays en
développement d'ici la fin du mois